hey i'm vanessa hudgins and i play stacy
margaret and fiona in the princess
switch switched again
i'm here with buzzfeed and i'm about to
take a quiz to figure out
which vanessa hudgins character i am
most like
[Music]
i have to choose my favorite festive
drink we have
eggnog which i've actually never tried
hot chocolate
apple cider or mulled wine my favorite
is mulled wine i make it
every holiday so yeah choose a christmas
activity
building a snowman decorating the tree
making a gingerbread house
singing christmas carols writing letters
to santa or going on a sleigh ride
i'm gonna have to go with singing
christmas carols i started a new
tradition where i hire a pianist for
my holiday party which obviously will
not be happening this year but
eventually and she comes the booklet and
everyone sits around the piano and
scream sings christmas carols basically
pick a dessert
cookies cupcakes brownie or pie i'm not
really like a sweets person
i'd rather eat pasta for dessert but
this is a red velvet cupcake and that is
my cake of choice
if i have to pick some cupcakes what is
your favorite part of christmas getting
time off from work
the food the parties the presents
spending time with family
the music and decorations maybe i'll go
with
the music and the decorations or
spending time with family
sorry music and decorations choose
another
netflix christmas movie a christmas
prince holiday
jingle jangle a christmas journey
holiday in the wild
let it know or the holiday calendar imma
support my girl emma roberts
and say holiday pick a christmas song
underneath the tree by kelly clarkson
all i want for christmas is you by
mariah carey
santa tommy by ariana grande christmas
in the hollies
by run dmc santa baby by eartha kitt or
felice navidad
by jose feliciano i
am a sucker for old school jazzy
christmas music
so definitely santa baby by earth kit
finally have you been naughty or nice i
think that if you've been naughty you
should reevaluate
your life so nice
[Music]
i got luna pembroke of course i did
because
i created her i birthed her from my own
brain
whoever said having a good time was a
crime you're fun
magnetic and the life of every party you
love finer things in life and you
strive to enjoy everything you do
sometimes you struggle with the weight
of responsibility
and the pressure to live up to
expectations
triggers your fight or flight response
you may run away from your problems but
no matter what you learn
from your mistakes deep down you're a
person with a big heart
wants to do the right thing fiona
well there you have it i am most like
fiona pembroke which is not really a
surprise
because make sure you guys watch the
princess which switched again
coming to you on netflix november 19th
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you